but what's the problem so we want to
determine the chromatic number for
sequence of random crafts GN with a
probability so the chromatic number is
the smallest number of colors I need to
gather my random graph so such that no
two incident vertices get the same color
so this is a question with which stated
at least for the Edit rainy model in
their seminal paper not from 1960 by
aderson rainy and the model which has
received the most attention of hard to
certainly the random regular aircraft
and this is what I'm going to talk about
so I don't want to bother you with this
slide I just want to find out that
there's amount of work which is done on
this question so I I've mixed so the
first results are all results for the
error for any case and I mixed sparse
and ends with dreams so at some points
the the average degree is dependent on
enron and some some of these cases the
independent rains a constant so let me
just point you to the to the best result
for the editor any case which was
obtained by I mean and tangible in cheek
2013 where they showed our determined
the chromatic number for the a deterrent
rainy graph for almost all about almost
all bonded eyelids all right for almost
half of all bonded turkeys and nope no
sorry yet no I'm mixed up a bit they
really determined the chromatic number
for the editor any case for almost all
bond the decrease and for the regular
case the best previous result was by
camp Parris luminescent warmers fun too
from 2010 where they resolve the Bourbon
for about half of all ye but I will
explain the proof techniques and how
they receive this was a little bit later
on so
yes so the best previous we start on the
regular case is what I stated that 4k
larger than 3 or butter and equal then
three they determine the chromatic
number four for all these which fall in
this interval which is roughly of
lengths low key and they determined the
chromatic number before they showed the
concentration on these two consecutive
numbers for these which fall in this
interval which is also of lengths lock a
roughly this implies are better to say
this result comes from bounds on the
cake a durability problem so they show
that the random break like gear regular
graph ask a colorable with high
probability of D is smaller than this
lower bound and it fails to be cake LOL
with high probability if these larger
than this upper bound all right so our
reside and stop this one so if K is
larger or equal than three the existent
error sequence which tends to 0 with k
such this is true so if he is smaller
than out our bond then yeah they're in
regular graph is cake a level with high
probability and if these latter is not
cake edible with high probability and
let me first give you the remark that
this is an improved lower and an
improved upper bound yeah so this
implies to call corollary so if you if
you look at the problem asking for the
question is a given crab with a the fix
d is it que calor will then you get this
car up corollary which is again get an
error term which tends to 0 and then we
define the interval which is just the
interval between the lower and the upper
bound and define this DK call at the
unique integer which is contained in
this interval if there's an integer
I contained and if not we just take the
midpoint of this interval and then we
can state that if d is smaller than this
DK call which is well defined then our
random do regular cough SDK colorable
with high probability and if d is larger
than this number then in phase 2 b.k
callable filled with high probability so
as you might see that this interval has
length 0 point three eight six plus some
some error which tends to 0 with K so if
this DK call is no no integer then we
have solved the cake color ability
problem completely and if the let me
find out that the set for our case for
which this is not an integer this DK
call this is asymptotic density roughly
point 6 14 so this is by White's
criteria so roughly for a fraction of
all this case we've solved the KCAL
ability problem completely the other
implication is if you she asked the
chromatic number of the random regular
craft then we stayed the following this
is a sequence which has asymptotic
density one and there's an explicit
function such that for all the in lab
see we have that the chromatic number is
really determined by this function
explicitly so if you look at this of
this picture so every once in a while
your defaults in this interval and then
you then we have not determined the
chromatic number exactly for this D but
the length of this interval is constant
when K increases and the steps between
two intervals ik and FK plus one is of
size tool ok so we've solved yeah the
chromatic number problem for almost all
the
only once in a while there's some D
which falls in such an interval where it
it's not clear if it's k or k plus 1 the
chromatic number alright so how's this
result received so the best current
reside precise on the coloring of a
trainee correct aircraft or the regular
graph are obtained by the SEC moment
method as you probably know and so are
present resize so the second moment
method just let me stand with remind
remind you so you take a some random
variable which is non-negative with the
properties that that if it's strictly
positive only if JJ s que es que calor
rule and then we can accept this by this
pal a segment inequality if we can show
that the second moment is upper bound by
constant times the square of the first
moment this implies that ya satta
strictly positive the probability that a
set a strictly positive is lower bounded
by 1 over C and of course this is not an
this is not what we are really heading
for so we there's no but I probability
or this will not imply with high
probability so the probability tending
to oneness n tends to infinity but you
take this issue later so what random
variable is suitable so the first
simpler approach will be just count the
number of RK colorings but it is more
convenient to use the random variable of
balanced color k calories witches or
cake coloring such that all the K color
classes are the same of the same size
and over K and this is indeed the call
the alley optus now our proof from 2005
for the error for any case where they
prove the second moment bound for the
number of balance colorings yeah and how
we already have seen on Tuesday and
Chris
motox must talk and they solved a
relaxation of a non convex optimization
problem over the big book of poly 12
which is the set of all doubly
stochastic a 10 K times K matrices and
in the edit or any case the probability
can be boosted to 1 minus little fun by
means of a shaft a short result bialya
Preston free good so unfortunately in
the elders in the rent and regular case
we don't have these fresh at least the
threshold reside and so the result
obtained by camp compares to Millicent
warmer from 2010 was they used the
solution of Valley after Sonora as a
black box and they get the got the
concentration by the small sub graph
conduct conditioning technique which is
so what they observed is that these
constancy that creeps into the same
moment bound on that results actually
from the existence of of short cycles in
the random regular graph and yes yeah
it's well known that to the neighborhood
in there in at least in the sparse
regime for the constant the typical
neighborhood of over Texas and locally
tree like arson supposed to be a tree
but there exists a small number of short
cycles a bounded number and and yeah
actually if you carefully control the
impact of these of the number of these
short cycles you can reduce the variance
abuse will boost the probability to 1
minus little o of 1 so
so for the air in case again the best
results recent results by a query oak
and villain cheek was obtained again by
a second moment but the second moment
methods the lower bond for they use the
different random variable they used the
number of so-called good k calories and
I will explain now what what makes the
difference to just computing the second
moment for balance k colorings and it
was actually annotation from non
rigorous statistical mechanics works on
randoms constraint satisfaction problems
which facilitates the computation of the
second moment a lot so this picture case
has to be in every choice so so Maya
this is a physicist pictures or your
picture for the solution space geometry
of random constraint satisfaction
problems just wanted to mention that
yeah at the space solution space and a
regime we are interested in which is
close to the satisfiability que calor
ability threshold close to the
condensation fair shot so the solution
space shatters in these clusters and
yeah so not only they solutions where
shatters it's also true that we know at
least from the talk in front of me
before me that these clusters are also
very separated in this regime and yeah
so the main question is how can we
benefit from this picture and how can we
benefit which which depends of course on
the concrete Salloum you're looking on
and so how can we get this this cluster
definition running or working in a
appropriate right away for our concrete
problem we are looking on and this is
what I mean and then he did they so let
me first define the overlap of two
balanced maps and 2k
which is just the W stochastic matrix we
have seen on Tuesday which is the
fraction of vertices which are colored I
under Sigma and J under tau anomalous
pay and the fraction and times K so we
obtain a doubly stochastic matrix and
then we can compute the second moment
just by overlaps so the second moment is
roughly at the maximum of all these over
all these w stochastic matrices which
are feasible and then we yeah so this is
the novel a struggle rhythm of the
second moment this is the entropy term
and this is probability that's two
solutions with certain fixed over there
pro are both at two Catering's our
weather colorings for random random
random d regular and crafts so as such
as well known that the second mo method
works if it if the this maximum is
attended the maximize of the entropy
which is in this case the flat matrix
with all entries one over K
so so the set of all W stochastic
matrices is just big of polytope and if
you consider one of the of the vertices
of this big of papaya top for example
the the matrix with the identity matrix
and you you take a path towards these
flat matrix the 0 for 1 over K matrix
then you observe that these is function
so this one first increases to a local
Maxima maximum and then decreases again
and at the LED matrix interchange again
and a maximum so the second moment
method works if this Maximus instead
it's really a global maximum total
Maximizer and let me emphasize that in a
sense so this maximum comes from
colorings which are very close so the
corners of this book of volatile
correspond so so exactly the identity
matrix the overlap is only obtained if
you if Sigma equals to tau so if if they
are very similar look very similar then
the entropy part is of course very small
but of course the probability that both
Catering's are valid colorings for the
craft is maximized in this case and so
if you walk towards the inner point
robar then the entropy increases but the
probability decreases and you get this
picture so so the second moment really
works if this side maximum remains more
so something I will I don't prove it
just tell you is that this site maximum
corresponds to the expected class
resides in the Plantin order
so if you could if it would be right
that this expected size of the cluster
is blown up by relevance so of some
crafts you don't really see with a large
number of huge flash clusters then it
would be possible to to just just look
at calories which are which which occur
in classes with a typical size not on
the expected size or something like that
so this is actually true so if you if
you choose a random graph and you choose
uniformly at random k coloring the
classroo sighs sighs is exponentially
smaller than the expected cluster size
of this coloring and so I'm going to
define these are a try to get this in a
more formal way so we define the cluster
of a cake coloring Sigma to be the set
of all colorings that are bad balanced
and such that the overlap for the same
color is larger than 0 point five at
least 51 percent of the vertices in a
certain color class are I call it the
same under Sigma none at all
so and then we call the balance k
coloring separable if for any other
balance k coloring towel on any two
colors we have that if this overlap
parameter IJ is larger than 4.5 1 this
implies that is actually larger than 1
minus cover and covers of order little
01 so so this definition of class rule
does not imply that the cluster of two
colorings are either destroyed or
identical but if you if you look at
separable k colorings then this
condition ensures that the cluster our
classifier is a fees are identical or
destroyed so finally we define a balance
k coloring as good re call it good if
it's separable and the cluster size is
upper bounded by the expected number for
balance colorings normalized will then
alright so the second moment comes down
to as as you know probably to the
following question if you choose a pair
of good k colorings uniformly at random
and look at the overlap of this pair of
good k colorings then it has to be close
to the flat over limit overlap matrix
with high probability so then the
segment works and actually the notion of
God puts an a priori bound on the
cluster size and in some sense this hard
rise these classic geometry of the set
of K columns into the random variables
so we don't really have to consider
these pairs or these these overlaps
which are at the side so we can totally
forget about the side maximum and only
have to optimize the maximization
problem over the yep around the flat
matrix this is really necessary without
an explicit bound on the cluster size
the contribution of these kind of
overlaps would exceed the contribution
of uncorrelated pass so the remaining
attacks is then to show that in the
random regular crap it's true that the
expected number of good colorings is
roughly the same as the number of Power
Balance colorings
or this sketch of the offer proof for
the lower bound is then we could use the
solution of the segment calculation for
the adage rainy case by creo plan
valença guess black box we also could
use the small sub graph conditioning
argument as a black box and we really
had to had to estimate the typical
cluster size are an upper bound on it
for the regular case and this
computations are done in the planted
model and also the computations had to
be performed the configuration model
which is which you usually do if you
consider a regular model and we need to
estimate the number of frozen vertices
by a core process or the pictures in
this picture also a lot of time this
this week so there are some variables
which are which are really frozen so
they have live neighbors in every color
class so if you flip one of these
vertices then you have to flip a huge
amount of medinia at additional vertices
but they are of course there's a few
free vertices which are free in that in
the sense that they could be colored in
two colors and you don't have to have to
recolor and a large number of vertices
to make a make it again a valid coloring
all right so let me say something about
the improved upper bond because i think
it's it's interesting since oblivious
besides simply use the simple first
moment at her bond over the number of RK
colorings and we actually used a
technique which was developed in a paper
about the k not equal sad problem by
Amica oakland and panna guru and let me
also mention that there's an improved
upper bond on the que calor ability and
father at or any case by i mean but this
was by a different approach he actually
computed the first moment upper bond for
curve
so if you just compute the first moment
then you observe that if your B is
larger than 2k minus 1 okay these this
expected value of the number of our k
Catering's is exponentially small and n
but if we define D plus which is our
upper bound in the que calor ability
property then there's of course at most
1 D 1 integer integer in this in this
regime between D plus and the trivial
first moment upper bond and yeah if you
compute the first moment you observe
that yeah the normalized logarithm is
still positive strictly positive and
this is actually no no accident
indeed it's the case that the first
moment is driven up by again by rare
events so they are a few so if you if
you choose your uniform the arraignment
d regular craft and then your test with
high probability not even one solution
but there are a few crafts which have a
lot of number or a huge number of
solutions and so what we did is so yeah
if you choose one of these graphical
solution then you observe that the
number of this of this the number of
solutions are colorings in this trap is
really huge so what we have to have to
do or what you did as we perform the
first moment argument and which took
this will this size of the number of
solutions in account a salon sketch of
the proof so by the physics picture the
cake colorings come in clusters so if we
could obtain a lower lower bound on the
cluster size of a typical cake coloring
sigma and show that this is actually
larger than the then the are
exponentially larger than the expected
number of our colorings we can just
apply the macro see a Marcus inequality
and obtain that there is the probability
that there is the cake coloring is the
loved one so how do did we do this so
let me define a rainbow coloring so if
you take a parameter P and then to walk
in the unit's a wall and okkk coloring
Sigma then you we say that a vertex is
rainbow if it has in each color but its
own color at least one neighbor W such
that yeah and we call Sigma P rainbow of
precepts VPN vertices a rainbow so you
could think of these vertices as the
vertices which are determined to the
cutter which is
modest and all these the vertices with
that are not rainbow could be colored in
at least one different color than their
own now we define the cluster which is a
similar definition as we had seen before
but we are now letting the balanced
condition because we have really took to
count carefully in this regime and we
define a que coloring Sigma nice if our
color classes have size about roughly n
over K so they are close to be balanced
the edge densities between different
color classes are approximately uniform
and it hit it entails some kind of
stability so such that these clusters
are disjoint are identical so I don't
gave you the technical definitions but
this is the idea and then finally we may
define Sigma a que killing Sigma SP
heavy if it is nice it is p rainbow and
the cluster size is lower bounded by 2
to the N times YP where IP is roughly 1
minus P so this is roughly the fraction
of vertices that are not P rainbow so in
a sense what this says is that you can
cover all on your nut rainbow so you're
free vertices with two colors at these
two colors and this you can do
independently so there are no
correlations between these three
variables so roughly speaking so finally
if you if we set this if we said data to
be the center wall around 1 minus 1 over
K then we have to care only about P
heavy cake aligns with P in this
interval so all the other p heavy k
calories don't appear so the expected
value of F just tends to 0 is small and
if P is in this interval we are able to
compute the expected number of these of
these P heavy
k Catering's so we would be done if if
it would be true that for all p heavy k
colorings sigma or k colorings in this
cluster are also p heavy then we could
simply multiply the our lower bond of
the class size times the expected
expected value of the number of all of
these PFE k calories and would observe
that this is exponentially small and
then finally what we would sum over all
of an possible values of P bad
unfortunately this is not true so this
is also true but we get around of this
bipartition data into tiny intervals
that one to tell jas with really small
length and then we define set j to be
the number of p heavy k coloring such
that p a force in this interval delta j
then you some with something up we
define this nice set Jane to be the sum
over all I from j two s and what we
simply computers that this expected
expected where you have set jay is lower
bound by YP j so finally we succeed by a
receiver induction over the index of the
partition of of data so if you are given
a pj heavy k coloring sigma then you
know that the cluster is at least of
this size on the cluster size on the
analogy of this set is at least two to
the N ypj and then by induction this
luster only contains p prime heavy k
coverings for p prime which is oh sorry
this should be larger than p and since
we could compute this we simply apply
marcos inequality and this year's that
the expected value of these Ted said j m
is little one since the total number of
in towards responded as n tends to
infinity we are
so you isn't so due to the physicist
activity computation am so what but you
you think the real editor the complete
answer for this program would be is this
ad k which is the solution of this
equation and this complexity function
and so what I wanted to say is the first
thing is that there's a concrete
conjecture where this cake a durability
threshold exactly lies and the synthetic
expansion needs our upper bound and of
course we know why it should be hard to
close this little remaining gap and for
the elf any case we have proven the
existence of the condensation phase
transition rigorously and let me also
mention that they are results entering
this condensation face like for the
random case a problem by Sting slant son
but it seems to be hard to apply these
resize since in yeah in this case we are
we have a casement model so um so there
so the solutions approach would be very
very high dimensional so it seems to be
really hard to to play that this
approach to the KCAL ability problem
either Eva even for at the end of any
case or the regular case all right thank
is the technical challenge if you wanted
to generalize this to like non regular
graphs a configurational mom like it can
be fixed sequence of 15 years what about
it so which are the points which would
be hard if you wanted to generalize this
is taken for saqqaq crap with what the
given decrease accounts for example mix
of 3 and 4 mm I don't know if this that
would be you problem so I have to think
about it palette and so I think it
should be doable I think I don't know to
be honest
it's a very good question i I've never
seen anyone doing a very tight bound
program so I don't want me they are a
lot of expert in the room so is that a
technical problem to do it so I want to
get just the time that you get from the
cat intimated bowel for color ability
just by but using well they're like I
don't think I'd ever seen this good
people do it off sack I don't know there
is for color on there is it works it
works they can we do it all so far off
already regular grant
well maybe did something to the
Christian yeah so I just there's another
nice random variable that you can use
her first moment upper bound sometimes
comes from a nice a parametric and
quality on computers if you take the
product over all vertices of one over
the number of available colors which is
also a kind of naive approach to take to
divide away the cluster size because it
may've Lee assumes that the size of the
cluster is the product over the vertices
of the number of available polymers so
then this this also gives some
improvements for some other source of
coloring problem set my favorite right
now and it's often it is quite easy to
deal with yeah just yep
Oh